vous êtes sur
[Musique]
RTL le Grand Jury présenté par Olivier
Bost bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
grand jury en direct sur RTL et sur
Paris Première bonjour Marc fen bonjour
vous êtes ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire vous êtes
surtout ce matin le ministre d'un monde
agricole en colère éleveur viticulteur
producteur laitiers céréaliers la
campagne grond contre la concurrence
étrangère l'inflation les normes
environnementales et l'Europe la colère
de nos campagnes sera-t-elle l'enjeu
numéro1 d'ailleurs de la campagne des
européennes le rassemblement national
s'active bienvenue dans ce grand jury
Marc fen pour vous interroger à mes
côtés ce dimanche Pauline buisson de la
rédaction d' M6 et Loris Boichot du
fidaro euh le Premier ministre Gabriel
Atal Marc fenud hier dans le rô a dit
l'agriculture est un sujet absolument
majeur première question Pauline buisson
oui et dans le même temps Bruno leemire
le ministre de l'Économie annoncé la
multiplication des contrôles sur les
négociations commerciales en cours pour
assurer le revenu des agriculteurs vous
vous étiez aussi en déplacement sur le
terrain hier l'Élysée a demandé à tous
les préfets d'aller voir les
agriculteurs ce weekend et Gabriel hatal
demain rencontrera le principal syndicat
agricole à FNSEA est-ce que nons pas un
peu la la panique Marc F non c'est pas
du tout une question de panique d'abord
on a toujours été sur le terrain j'ai
toujours été sur le terrain à la
rencontre des agriculteurs en même temps
il y a un moment d'exaspération qui se
manifeste et donc être au côté des
agriculteurs essayer d'écouter ce qu'ils
veulent essayer d'apporter des solutions
on peut pas à la fois reprocher parfois
de ne pas écouter quand on écoute de
dire vous écoutez trop vous écouteriez
est est-ce que ça donne une idée de la
de la situation tout le gouvernement sur
le terrain mobiliser sur le sujet de la
si vous me permettez de dire un mot de
ce que je perçois de cette crise d'abord
on a une crise qui vient d'abord de
l'Europe
collectivement dans un certain nombre de
pays des agriculteurs se rassemblent
c'est ça a commencé au Pays-Bas il y a
quelques mois puis en Allemagne puis en
Roumanie puis en Pologne on me dit qu'il
y a eu des sujets aussi en Espagne ou en
Italie et puis c'est en France aussi sur
différents sujets qui sont d'abord sans
doute le rapport à l'Europe mais je vais
y revenir sur la question du rapport à
l'Europe d'abord il y a une for une
forme de crise de foi foi des
agriculteurs c'estàdire qu'il n'y
croient plus ils ont le sentiment qu'on
leur donne des injonction qui est celle
de produire plus des produits de qualité
mais qui a pas la rémunération ça amène
au sujet des négociations commerciale
sur lequel chacun a faire sa part mais
on y reviendra sans doute tout à l'heure
il y a un deuxième sujet c'est une crise
de la norme norme européenne ou norme
nationale et la surnormation le la
sédimentation d'un certain nombre de
normes produit de l'exaspération il y a
parfois aussi une exaspération de la
crise du modèle c'est il y a un certain
nombre de territoirees je pense à
l'Occitanie où le dérèglement climatique
les modèles d'agriculture qui sont sur
la table posent des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes profonds et puis il y a un
sujet j'y reviens sur la question
européenne c'est est-ce que la politique
européenne agricole qui la la politique
la plus intégrée c'est celle qui est le
premier la première le premier poste de
dépense il y a des députés européens qui
sont ici présents est-ce que la
politique européenne sert ou pas la
souveraineté je vais vous donner un seul
exemple et qui nourrit aussi la colère
au niveau européen et au niveau national
nous nous importion il y a 2 ans 20
millions de tonnes de céréales ce qui
est déjà beaucoup cette année en 2023
l'année qui se termine on a importé 40
millions de tonnes de céréales en
particulier lié au problème de
dérèglement climatique et dans le même
temps l'Europe nous dit il faut 4 % de
jacher reconnaissez que de dire on gèle
une capacité productive aussi
puissamment quand on importe aussi
puissamment ça pose une question de
cohérence de la politique européenne
donc on a besoin à la fois d'avoir une
stratégie de transition écologique mais
une transition écologique qui serent la
souveraineté et qui ne viennent pas la
desservir dans un monde singulièrement
qui s'est quand même déréglé depuis 2019
avant de développer tous les sujets que
vous venez d'évoquer Marc fenau on va
revenir sur la situation vraiment
française et politique selon la lettre
politico Emmanuel Macron redoute les
manifestations d'agriculteur d'un en
effet boule de neige un façon gilet
jaune pouvez-nous vous nous confirmer
que c'est ce que ce que le chef de
l'État a dit en conseil des ministre
mercredi mais le chef de l'État nous a
demandé collectivement d'abord c'est pas
qu'un sujet du ministère de
l'Agriculture collectivement de nous
mobiliser pour percevoir ce que cette
crise et j'ai essayé d'en donner
quelques éléments on y reviendra tout à
l'heure et deuxièmement d'essayer d'y
répondre c'est ça qu'il faut faire
question n'est pas d'avoir la crainte de
tel ou tel sujet principalement le sujet
c'est de répondre aux sujets qui sont
exprimés par les agriculteurs est-ce que
malgré tout 5 ans après les gilets
jaunes vous ne craignez pas euh le
retour des gilets verts mais mais je je
il y a toujours ceux qui essaient
d'agiter il y en a quelques-uns dans le
monde politique essaient d'agiter le le
remake de tel ou tel mouvement chaque
mouvement a ses spécificités là on a un
mouvement de nature agricole avec des
agriculteurs qui sont souvent emprint de
beaucoup de responsabilités et aussi
beaucoup de désespérances euh n'essayons
pas de comparer les choses là on a
quelque chose qui est multiforme en
terme de d'injonction de demande de
crise qui est la sédimentation de
plusieurs sujets ce que j'ai essayé de
dire c'est pas le sujet gilets jaunes
qui part sur un sujet principal qui
était l'affaire d'une taxe donc c'est
pas n'essayons pas de faire des
amalgames et puis pour ceux qui rêvent
de la Révolution essayons plutôt de
résoudre les problèmes parce que moi je
pense qu'on a besoin un moment dans les
crises d'essayer d'en sortir quelque
chose les crises agricoles il y en a eu
nombreuses il y a eu des crises dans les
années 60 qui étaient la crise de
comment on a on rentre dans le modèle de
production il y a eu des crises
viticoles qui ont été nombreuses et à
chaque fois on a essayé parce qu'on
s'est mis autour de la table avec le
mononde agricole de la surmonter et ça a
fait la puissance agricole française que
passant d'une crise à un dialogue pour
la surmonter on a réussi à à les crise
là est marquée par un certain nombre
d'actions coup de point en Occitanie
l'autoroute A64 est coupée par des
tracteurs depuis 4 jours et vendredi une
explosion a visé à Carcassonne un
bâtiment vide de la direction régionale
de
l'environnement qu'est-ce que vous
demandez à ceux qui sont responsables de
ces actions coup de point est-ce que
vous les appeler à la responsabilité
est-ce que vous condamnez d'abord
distinguons les choses il y a des
actions coup de point puis il y a des
actions très violentes il est
insupportable que le bâtiment soit vide
ou pas vide d'ailleurs qu'il a des
actions volentes m'avez toujours trouvé
sur le chemin de la dénonciation de la
violence pas vous m'avez déjà entendu le
dire je ne trie pas dans la violence
donc il faut la justice est saisie et
j'espère qu'on trouvera les auteurs de
quelque chose si quelqu'un était passé
par hasard dans ce dans ce bâtiment à ce
moment-là pour une raison ou pour une
autre et qu'il avait été blessé ça
aurait été évidemment beaucoup plus
grave donc certains écologistes parlent
d'ailleurs d'Agri terrorisme est-ce que
c'est une expression que vous je prends
pas les mots moi je je ne suis pas dans
la surenchè des mots je dis juste que je
dénonce la violence d'où qu'ell
vienneent et que donc la violence ne
peut pas être un moyen d'action après
j'appelle chacun la raison et
reconnaissons que y compris quand il y a
eu des manifestations VI à Saint Soline
les agriculteurs ont fait plan de
grandes responsabilités pour ne pas
rentrer dans cette surenchè donc
j'appelle tout le monde à ne pas rentrer
dans cette surenchè et ne pas rentrer
dans la sur enchè c'est aussi ouvrir les
voies du dialogue ça facilite les
questions de dialogue et compris dans le
rapport à la société just et est-ce que
vous demandez aux agriculteurs de de
libérer l'autoroute à 64 B je trouve que
la raison voudrait ça surtout qu'on a
essayé de répondre à un certain nombre
de leur sujets il y a des sujets qu'ils
avaient mis sur la table dans cette
région qui souffre particulièrement he
il faut le dire en particulier d'une
crise viticole il était prévu que
j'aille dans une dizaine de jours
apporter des réponses complémentaires à
C celle qu'on a apporté sur les sujets
viticoles ils ont une crise qui monte
qui est une crise de la ce qu'on appelle
la maladie hémorragique épisotique sur
les bovvins qui pèse lourdement sur ces
exploitations allez vous allez encore
attendre 10 jours avant d'y aller non
non attendez j'ai donné des éléments des
éléments de réponse sur cette maladie en
prenant en charge un certain nombre
d'indemnisations les frais vétérinaires
la perte d'animaux et cetera à hauteur
très significative donc on on commence à
à tirer les fils de réponses qui avaient
été préparé qui sont déployé dans dans
dans la dans le temps qu'il faut parce
que
je sais qu'on est dans le monde de
l'immédiaté vous me dites on n pas vous
me dites à la fois vous avez
l'impression d'aller trop vite et quand
on dit il faut qu'on fasse des choses
sérieuses et qui répondent réellement au
besoins des agriculteurs vous me dites
ça va trop lentement les agriculteurs
demandent la venue de de Gabriel Atal
vous j'ai dit dans la presse Gabriel
Attal nous en parlons très régulièrement
il est très mobilisé sur ce sujet comme
sur tous les autres il viendra en temps
et en heure mais là on est sur un sujet
où il faut qu'on d'abord qu'on déploie
les dispositifs et après qu' voit mais
on peut pas être sous une injonction
c'est pas la c'est pas la venue du
Premier ministre ou du ministre qui
résout seul les situations c'est
d'essayer de répondre concrètement au
sujets qui sont posés on a on a commencé
on va continuer de répondre concrètement
je reviens juste sur les blocages de
route parce que par exemple quand il y a
eu des actions du même type de la part
du des soulèvements de la terre par
exemple ou d'autres associations
écologistes ils ont été rapidement
évacués il y a eu des intervention
rapide est-ce que là il y aura une ça
fait quand même 4 jours appartient au
préfet et au ministre de l'Intérieur et
nous en parlerons voyez bien que
j'essaie de faire entendre il semble que
dans C dans ces moments là il faut faire
entendre j'allais dire le mot raison
mais quand il y a autant de désespérance
c'est plus compliqué à à à faire qu'à
dire reconnaissons-le mais en tout cas
on essaie d'apporter des réponses
concrètes parce que évidemment c'est que
dès qu'on bloque on prend des risques
sur d'autres qui prennent d'autres
chemins il y a des questions de sécurité
publique il y a des questions de
sécurité pour les agriculteurs eux-mêmes
il y a des questions de gens qui peuvent
finir par s'énerver de ces situations là
personne n'a intérêt à ce que se
cristallise de cette façonlà ces sujets
ça n'empêche pas que il y a des
engagements qui ont commencé à être pris
qu'on va continuer à mettre en œuvre et
qui permettront de répondre au vous
attendez que l'utoroute soit libérée
pour l'instant mais pas de mais c'est la
demande que je formule parce que je
pense que c'est une voie aussi de la
raison que d'essayer dans ce dans ce
moment-là de de de de dialoguer et pas
pour procrastiner et gagner du temps
mais de dialoguer et dialoguer ça peut
pas se faire uniquement en bloquant tel
ou telle route ou par tel ou tel
mouvement le Premier ministre Gabriel
Atal recevra demain le président de la
de la FNSEA premier syndicat agricole et
puis des jeunes agriculteurs également
c'est un indicateur de la gravité de de
la crise est-ce que le on peut dire que
le dossier est désormais géré
directement par par Matignon non il est
géré collectivement comme sur toute
crise euh le le Premier ministre d'abord
avait prévu d'en rencontrer l'ensemble
des syndicats et il était prévu aussi
qu'il rencontre la FNSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs les organisations donc
c'est pas de circonstance non non mais
on peut pas être sur des sujets comme ça
dans la circonstance par que si on est
simplement sur la circonstance on fait
comme beaucoup de gens on fait avant
nous donc on essaie de répondre
situation la je vous pose la question
parce que la FNSEA doit déterminer
notamment si elle enclanche ou pas des
mouvements d'ampleur dans la semain que
il est bien que le premier
ministrement il est bien que le premier
ministre conformément au plan qui était
prévu voir
les représentants syndicaux deuxième
élément je je verrai avec le Premier
ministre c'est syndicat parce que c'est
évidemment à la fois
une une intention que doit donner le
Premier ministre il doit donner un cap
et une direction on y reviendra sans
doute il l'avait dit il y a plusieurs
jours et le président de la République
il y a plusieurs semaines on a besoin de
simplifier un certain nombre de choses
donc c'est bien de voir les
organisations syndicales pour dire
qu'est-ce qu'on met sur la table en
terme de simplifiation est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que les organisations
syndicales sont en partie dépassé
aujourd'hui par je sa pas si de le dire
en tout cas moi ce que ce dont on a
besoin quand on est dans une crise comme
ça et quand vous regardez toutes les CR
de cette nature là ou d'autres crises on
a besoin de de parler avec des
interlocuteurs qui soient organisés qui
formulent des propositions qui soient
des propositions collective sans quoi il
y a un risque de durcissement est-ce que
vous vous pointez du doigt un risque de
durcissement de ce j'ai rien à pointer
du Doig en tout cas je souhaite que dans
au travers des organisations syndicales
agricoles dans leur diversité on essaie
de trouver les voies de les solutions
parce que sinon si c'est juste vous êtes
en TR de ce que vous êtes en train de
nous dire c'est que c'est pas forcément
le cas aujourd'hui on va voir dans les
jours et dans les semaines qui viennent
puisquils l'ont dit eux-même ils
souhaitent formuler un certain nombre de
propositions et donc à partir de ces
propositions là construisons il y a
parfois des les organisations syndicales
pu parfois il a des sujets de filières
sur lequels il faut qu'on travaille il
me semble que chacun doit se mettre au
travail de on a fait tout à l'heure le
parallèle avec les gilets jaunes est-ce
qu'il y a pas un point commun un
sentiment de de déclassement d'abandon
entre les gilets jaunes et les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui oui mais ce
sentiment il est le sentiment et le
produit et nous sommes tous alors nous
gouvernant en responsabilité mais nous
sommes tous en situation de
responsabilité quand vous dites aux
agriculteurs il faut faire des produits
de qualité et que la seule bataille qui
est menée c'est la bataille du prix le
plus bas il y a un sentiment
declassement quand vous décrivez une
activité agricole qui n'est pas la
réalité de ce qui vivent et vous leur
dit vous n'avez qu'à faire ça c'est très
simple il suffit les les Yaka foconises
de de de tout poil si je peux dire qui
en permanence au France viennent
d'expliquer aux agriculteurs ce qu'il
devrait faire parce que au fond ça
serait très simple de faire les
transitions il y a un sentiment de
déclassement quand vous dites aux
agriculteurs je donne un exemple très
concret on est très content d'avoir du
pastoralisme d'avoir des brebis et des
vaches et qu'en même temps on n pas on
n'est pas fichu de répondre à
l'injonction de ce que produit la
prédation sur ces territoires là ils ont
un sentiment non seulement déclassement
mais d'incohérence alors sur ce sur ce
sujet là en particulier on a avancé au
niveau européen sous l'impulsion
française puisque on va réexaminer le
statut du loup et ça permettra de mieux
juguler l'expansion de de de cette de ce
prédateur qui vient mettre en cause de
l'élevage dans plein de territoires donc
c'est ça qu'il faut et quand vous avez
une grande distribution
qui ne met ne met plus en exposition les
produits de qualité ou les produits bio
alors qu'on a demandé aux agriculteurs
de faire du produit bio ils disent c'est
quoi in jonction qui nous est demandé au
fond donc c'est un sentiment de
déclassement et d'incohérence collective
et j'entends certains qui viennent
parler de patriotisme le patriotiste
c'est que tout le monde à son échelle se
sent patriote il faut que les grands
distributeurs se sentent patriotes il
faut que la transformation se sent
patriote et il faut que dans la mesure
des moyens de chacun nous comme citoyens
on se sent patriotes de notre
agriculture parce que sinon les
agriculteurs ils ont le sentiment qu'en
fait personne n pas ne s'intéresse à eux
mais leur dit quelque chose qui est
totalement l'inverse de ce qui se passe
dans la réalité de nos pratiques de
grands distributeurs de de
transformateur ou de consommateur
Emmanuel Macron mardi soir lors de sa
conférence de presse a dit qu'il
souhaitait accroître dans les prochains
mois l'accompagnement des agriculteurs
est-ce que vous pouvez ce midi nous en
dire plus alors accroître
l'accompagnement c'est on va essayer de
faire plusieurs sujets le premier sujet
c'est la question des négociations
commerciales on est en plein d on a
besoin d'avoir des négociations
commerciales qui respectent la matière
première agricole et qui fassent qu'on
rémunère la matière première agricole
alors d'abord c'est une question de
respect de la loi d'où le fait que le
premier ministre et le le ministre de
l'économie et des finances annoncé
la multiplication des contrôles parce
qu'il y a des gens qui essaient de
détourner la loi deè élément c'est faire
pensez notamment au lait par exemple je
pense particulière au lait ou à d'autres
mais le lait est un exemple assez créant
c'est 10 € de plus parfois pardon 10 €
de plus grand surfac cherch à l'acheter
en dessous du bataille sur le lait parce
que c'est un produit imp plan
emblématique qui est une bataille folle
avec des écarts de 30 à 50 € les 1 litr
qui sont incompréhensibles 10 € pour
1000 l ça fait 0,01 centimes par litre
je dis pas que c'est rien mais je dis
que la grande distribution sur les
transformateurs doivent faire leur part
de l'effort collectif parce que
j'entends aussi un certain nombre de ces
acteurs nous expliquer qu'il se demande
si dans 5 10 15 ou 20 ans ce que disent
aussi les agriculteurs ils auront encore
de la matière première mais si vous
voulez de la matière il faut la payer
donc vous appelez à un geste de leur
part j'attends j'attends un Gest
négociation j'attends dans les
négociations commerciales 1 de respecter
la loi et s'il la respecte pas les
contrôles viendront leur rappeler leurs
injonctions et leurs obligations
j'attends deuxièmement un geste de
penser leur système sur le long terme
pour qu'il s'assurent que les
producteurs sont bien rémunéré sinon à
la fin ils disparaissent et c'est
valable sur le lait comme sur d'autres
produ accroîre l'accpagnement des des
agriculteurs quand le président de la
République disait ça ça voulait dire des
moyens supplémentaire d'aide deuxème
élément c'est je poursuis effectivement
la réponse vous avez raison de de me
rappeler à cela deuxème élément c'est
dans les grandes transitions de mettre
des moyens supplémentaires pour les
accompagner je pense à ce qu'on a fait
sur le budget le budget du ministère de
l'agriculture c'est près d'un milliard
d'euros de plus y compris sur un triénal
c'est pas one shot c'est pour plusieurs
années 1 milliard d'euros pour
accompagner la décarbonation 1li ardeur
pour accompagner territorialement la
souveraineté c'est c'est en plus des
budgets européens c'est en plus des
budgets européens c'est en plus des 9
milliards de la p le budget de
l'agriculture c'est environ 5 milliards
1 milliard de plus ça fait 20 %
d'augmentation c'est le budget qui
augmente le plus donc on met des moyens
auprès des agriculteurs pour les
accompagner dans les transitions et pour
améliorer leur compétitivitré tout ils
sont en colère alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire oui mais parce que y il y a
un moment vous savez dans les colères il
y a un moment de sédimentation de sujet
ù et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'accélérer ils ont le sentiment que ça
ne va pas assez vite l'affaire du loup
ça fait 20 ans qu'on le dit l'affaire
déjà cher j'ai pris le lad au niveau
européen il y a 22 pays qui suivent la
demande avec des parlementaires
européens que la Commission bouge il
faut qu'elle bouge enfin ce que vous
dises les agriculteurs quand même c'est
que jusque là en matière européenne vous
avez plutôt largement suivi et transposé
et surtransposé même tout ce qui venait
de l'Europe notamment dans le dans le
domaine de l'agriculture c'est c'est un
peu une nouvelle philosophie que vous
avez vis- deur les choses plus
simplement que ça il y a des règles
européennes qui sont issues de ce qu'on
a appelé le Green Deal on va pas rentrer
dans les détails mais il faut qu' qu' ça
c'était 2019 il vous aura pas échappé
que depuis 2019 il s'est passé deux
trois choses la première c'est la crise
covid qui a montré la fragilité de nos
systèmes et de nos interdépendance et le
fait qu'il suffisait que le monde se
bloque pour qu'on manque de tel ou tel
produit pour le monde agricole y compris
et la chaîne alimentaire a tenu elle a
tenu aussi parce qu'il y a des
agriculteurs qui sont allés tous les
jours s'occuper de vérifier que tout ça
fonctionnait avec la grande distribution
et la transformation mais tout le monde
s'y est mis première prise de conscience
deuxième prise de conscience c'est la
guerre en Ukraine nous avions construit
un modèle au niveau européen où les
angrais ils étaient en Biélorussie et en
Russie on a besoin d'angrais en
agriculture pour ceux qui l'auraient
oublié et donc on a besoin de de
repenser ces sujets là au niveau
européen on a besoin on peut pas parler
de souveraineté énergétique de
souveraineté technologique et de pas se
préoccuper de la première des
souverainetés c'est de savoir qui nous
nourrit qu-ce que et donc on a besoin
pardon sur le Green Deal d'interroger le
Green Deal dans ce qu'il a dans ses
fondements de 2019-28 est-ce qu'il
assure la souveraineté manifestement
nous ne sommes pas au rendez-vous et
donc il faut interroger mais c'est ce
qu'on interroger ça veut dire mettre sur
pause certains vol la question sur c'est
est-ce que est-ce que dans la transition
on est bien au rendez-vous aussi de la
souveraineté c'estàd qu'à chaque fois
qu'on pose un acte est-ce que c'est
cohérent avec et les deux peuvent être
cohérent parce que on a besoin
d'embarquer la transition parce que le
dérèglement climatique il va
profondément changer le modèle agricole
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais il
faut pas le faire pour que ça soit un
affaissement si ça aboutit j'ai vu des
simulations et donc on ça fait des mois
qu'on qu'on y travaille aussi avec la
commission européne des simulations où
ils expliquaient que benoitement qu'on
pouvait perdre 5 10 15 20 % de
production sur la viticulture ils ont
dit allez moins 30 % et tout ça va très
bien il y a des systèmes économiques
puis derrière il y a des hommes et des
femmes donc c'est impossible d'entendre
ce discours là quand la la le sujet
agricole est aussi puissant dans le
monde en terme géopolitique et quand le
besoin agricole est aussi puissant en
terme de sécurité donc on a besoin de
travailler sur ce sujetl c'est la
demande qu'on a fait sur la jacher les
parlementaires européens du groupe renu
en particulier ils sont beaucoup batttu
sur ce sujet là pour il y a il y a des
réglementations qu'on a qu'on a revu je
pense à ce qu'on avait appelé
restauration de la nature en fait la
version initiale c'était 30 % de
terre capacité réelle à produire bon on
a obtenu quelque chose qui soit beaucoup
moins fort et qui permette à la fois
d'amener la transition mais qui ne soit
pas la stérilisation 30% des terres
agricoles européennes et donc cette
bataille là n'est pas nouvelle cette
bataille là doit s'accélérer puis par
ailleurs ça c'est les parlementaires
européens mais ça c'est les attendez ça
c'est les gouvernements nationaux et
puis il faut que la Commission
européenne écoute et ben alors justement
justement est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec Christian Lambert l'ancienne
présidente de la FNSA qui aujourd'hui
des responsabilités au niveau européen
qui dit dans la tribune dimanche la
Commission européenne nécoute pas les
agriculteurs et c'est à cause de cette
accumulation de mauvaise décisions que
la colère explose j'ai l'impression
qu'elle dit la même phrase que moi de
façon différente ou et donc je serai
miainant donc c'est la faute à l'Europe
là non je ne dis pas ça puisque l'Europe
c'est aussi nous mais la Commission
européenne elle est ce qu'elle est dans
ses fonction il y a un Parlement puis il
y a des il y a des États-membres et donc
y compris pour pour que l'esprit
européen persiste parce que nous avons
besoin d'Europe moi je le dis parce que
c'est pas de moins d'Europe dont on a
besoin demandez aux Anglais ce que ça a
fait le brexit pour eux les agriculteurs
angis anglais les agriculteurs anglais
ils sont en train de se déclasser
totalement il y aura plus d'agriculture
anglaise bientôt parce que ils ont
renationalisé leur système puisqu'ils
sont sortis de l'Europe ils ont des des
aides qui sont beaucoup moins puissantes
et ils ont pas la protection de l'Europe
sur un certain nombre de sujets donc on
a besoin d' eux qui manifeste
aujourd'hui hein mais c'est pas eux qui
manifeste aujourd'hui ENF oui mais parce
qu'ils sont en nom beaucoup moins
puissant parce que l'agriculture
anglaise déjà était en grande difficulté
mais il faut se poser cette questionl et
donc on a besoin au niveau européen
c'est pas c'est pas la question c'est
pas de dire c'est la faute à l'Europe ou
pas la faute à l'Europe c'est la
question de prendre collectivement nos
responsabilités
la Commission européenne a mis le a
décidé de de mettre ce travail sur la
table maintenant j'attends des réponses
rapides je pense la question de la
jacher au niveau européen on a aussi un
travail qui est en train d'être fait que
nous avons accéléré sur les nouvelles
techniques génomiques qui vont permettre
de trouver des alternatives au produits
phytosanitaires parce qu'on peut pas
dire aux agriculteur faut les réduire on
vous donne pas de solution ben j'attends
que l'Europe accélère le process et de
votre côté votre projet de loi quand
est-ce que vous le présenterez en
conseil des ministres on pr alors vous
l'avez vu le premier ministre a dit que
y compris dans la la volonté que nous
avons d'accélérer un certain nombre de
simplification il y avait un certain
nombre de sujets qui étaient posés dans
le texte de loi qui était un texte
autour de l'installation le guichet
unique les fond de portage 400 millions
d'euros pour accompagner le portage du
foncier pour les jeunes 2 milliards
d'euros de garantie bancaire pour faire
en sorte que les jeunes pour aider à
l'installation des pour à l'inallation
vous voyez bien qu'on est dans un moment
où il faut accélérer dans le pacte
lui-même il y avait tous ces sujets
d'accélération qui étaient posés il y a
un besoin d'accélération prenons
quelques semaines pour regarder ce qu'on
peut mettre tout de suite dans le texte
pour y compris crédibiliser parce qu'on
a besoin de crédibiliser la parole
publique aussi dans le débat en général
dans le monde en Europe et en France
donc le projet de loi était pas
suffisamment ambitieux c'est ça que vous
nous dites en fait on avait dit qu'on
pouvait sur certains sujets prendre un
peu un peu de temps mais il y a
peut-être des sujets sur lesquels on
peut accélérer c'estàdire au lieu de
mettre un paquet de simplification qui
soit dans les quelques mois essayons de
le faire dans les quelques semaines donc
les sujets de simplification qu'on peut
mettre sur la table rapidement Metz
mettonsles sur la table mais vous êtes
prêt à ouvrir des sujets comme celui de
l'irrigation comme celui des des
pesticides notamment c'est vous alors je
vais vous donner des sujets de
simplification il y a des il y a deux
sujets pour moi de simplification trois
sujets le le premier je faire vite
pardon mais c'est les sujets importants
le premier sujet c'est on a des process
d'instruction de recours qui sont
beaucoup trop long vous avez des des
éleveurs qui aujourd'hui déposent un
dossier en 2020 et ont la réponse en
2025 dans l'intervalle les crédits ont
augmenté le système économique est plus
le même et par ailleurs parfois au
niveau européen on a rajouté des normes
voyez à peu près il y a quelque chose à
devenir fou dans donc on a besoin de
raccourcir les délais comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs sur la loi denergie énergie
pour essayer de de condenser les délais
c'est pas en rabattre c'est juste qu'on
a besoin de condenser les délais vos
deux autres points très rapidement les
deux autres points c'est de dire il y a
des normes il y a des successions nor je
donne un exemple très concret on veut
plus de en France c'est bon pour
l'agriculture c'est bon pour la
biodiversité c'est bon pour
l'environnement on a 12 textes qui
régissent donc on on a besoin de ça et
puis troisème élément le Premier
ministre l'a dit hier dans le rô c'est
très valable sur un certain nombre de de
secteurs il faut qu'on cesse en France
alors on a beaucoup limité mais il faut
qu'on cesse de faire de la
surtransposition c'estàdire qu'on a des
règles qui s'appliquent en France et qui
qui s'pplique pas en Europe parce qu'on
vient imputer ça à l'Europe mais en fait
on on devrait se poser la question à
chaque fois qu'on fait une norme de
est-ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle vient ou
pas àer si je peux dire la compétitivité
française mais toutes les
surtranspositions sont pas mauvaises la
loi Galim c'est une surtransposition le
système de retraite française c'est une
surtransposition puisque donc on a
besoin d'avoir des des des
réglementations françaises qui ne
viennent pas affaler notre compétitivité
et qui ne viennent pas nous mettre en
compétition avec nos voisins européens
parce qu'on est dans le même marché donc
il y a aucune logique on a les mêmes
consommateurs et on a les mêmes
exigences de santé globalement et donc
c'est de bon ton et et donc c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on regarde alors parfois
c'est untifs sont clair quel est le
pourquoi ne pas présenter votre projet
de loi dès la semaine prochaine comme
c'était prévu initialement quel est le
nouveau calendrier de ce projet de loi
alors je réponds à votre question pour
finir parce que j'essaie comme vous le
savez toujours de répondre aux questions
le projet de loi devit être présenté la
semaine prochaine vous voyez bien que
pour adjoindre quelques mesures
réglementaires il y a quand même des
sujets juridiques qu'il faut qu'on pose
et donc donnons-nous quelques semaines
et l'objectif c'est que dans le dans le
dans le semestre 2024 le texte soit
débattu à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat donc ça ne ça ne vient pas 1er
semestre 2024 ça ne vient pas obéré le
calendrier ça vient juste prenons le
temps si on peut essayer d'avancer très
vite sur un certain nombre de
simplification de le faire euh pour que
on puisse aussi crédibiliser notre
parole et puis par ailleurs les autres
sujets qui sont posés dans la loi
prenons le temps de voir comment évolue
le mouvement euh des agriculturs non il
y a pas non mais non pardon euh la
question n'est pas dire on prend le
temps on procrastine on attend de voir
si c'est puissant ou pas puissant le
sujet c'est pas ça le sujet c'est il y a
des sujets qui sont posés le président
dans la République lors de ses vœux et à
plusieurs reprises a dit qu'il voulait
qu'on œuvre sur les questions de
simplification allons sur la
simplification essayons de le mettre
rapidement sur le de de mettre le
l'ouvrage sur le métier et puis après on
avance pour avoir juste un repère vous
présentez ce projet de loi avant ou
après le Salon de l'Agriculture qui a un
moment important pour pour le secteur
oui alors enfin faut d'ailleurs je je me
permets de faire une remarque le S
d'agriculture c'est toujours un moment
où on s'intéresse à l'agriculture et je
suis très heureux d'ailleurs mais c'est
pas la première fois donc je nen fait
pas GRI d'être invité au Grand Jury
j'aimerais bien qu'on s'intéresse à
l'agriculture tous les jours toute je
l'anné et c'est pas un reproche mais
collectivement et pas seulement au
moment du Salon de la rép on encore loin
sal je vous fais pas le reproche je me
suis garé gardéire mais je vois bien que
tout le monde veut parler d'agriculture
depuis 3 jours les agriculteurs ils
auraient besoin qu'on pense à eux qu'on
parle d'eux et qu'on parle de
positivement tous les jours et donc on
verra si c'est autour du
salonagriculture mais l'idée c'est pas
d'attendre dans jambé ou pas c'est de
dire des choses dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent qui soient clair
vis-à-vis des agriculteurs et pour
aborder un autre sujet compliqué pour
les agriculteurs il y a celui de
l'inflation avec le prix des céréales
des engrais on en parlait certains sont
tombés dans le rouge à cause de cette
augmentation des prix qu'est-ce que
quelle est votre réponse sur ce sujetl
la réponse c'est celle de que cette
inflation soit prise en charge dans les
matières premières agricoles et qu'elle
se retrouve dans les prix que donc dans
les négociations commerciale la matière
première agricole soit soit pris en
c'est pas pour le coup c'est pas par les
aides mais vous pouvez pas aucun pays ne
prend en charge l'inflation par des
aides à la on l'a fait dans certains
secteurs question on l'a fait sur les
questions énergétiques ce qui revenait à
répondre d'ailleurs d'une certaine
passion au question d'inflation je
rappelle que nous sommes le pays ou l'un
des pays où l'inflation a été la plus
mesurée j'ai pas dit qu'elle a été nulle
j'ai pas dit qu'elle n'a pas existé mais
il faut quand même mesurer les choses et
donc la meilleure façon de le faire et
puis par ailleurs dans les normes il y a
du il y a du cout et c'est une façon
aussi de de de lutter et puis par
ailleurs il faut qu'on ait des débats au
niveau européen pour dire comment on
essaie de mieux organiser nos March
mondiaux pour que moi je me suis
déplacer à plusieurs reprises pour
essayer d'ouvrir des marchés discuter
avec les uns et les autres quand le
président de la République va en Chine
et il ouvre un March complémentaire sur
le port quand je dialogue de sur l'autre
rive de la Méditerranée pour regarder
comment on peut reprendre un train de de
d'exportation de céréales c'est un moyen
aussi de retrouver de la compétitivité
et des déboucher pour nos agriculteurs
la le problème des compétitions de la
compétitivité au niveau international
des importations on va en parler dans la
seconde partie du Grand Jury puis on va
parler encore de ces difficultés que
rencontrent les agriculteurs et de cette
colère qui monte à tout de suite pour la
seconde
partie
suite du Grand Jury présenté par Olivier
Bost Marc F le ministre de l'Agriculture
et l'invité de ce grand jury Marc F pour
être très concret je vous propose
d'écouter un agriculteur Bertrand lou
c'est un éleveur de beauovvin en
HauteGaronne au micro RTL de Patrick
hisson alors moi ce que j'aurais envie
de lui dire c'est que la politique c'est
les carrières c'est un passage mais par
cont contre on peut laisser une grande
marque j'aimerais savoir s'il n'aurait
pas envie d'être le ministre qui
améliore les conditions de vie des
agriculteurs qui soit affiché sur le mur
des personnes qui ont fait progresser
l'agriculture en France et
consolider l'activité nourricière et
vous lui demandez quoi immédiatement
rapidement immédiatement il faut
résoudre absolument cette problématique
du gasoil non routier ça fait partie de
notre base de revenu débloquer les fonds
pour la MHE très rapidement pour la
maladie qui touche les vaches voilà
exactement et une politique courageuse
de soutien à l'irrigation parce que
c'est la condition cinequanon pour avoir
une base de production stable et
d'avenir alors Marc fen avant de
répondre à ces trois points est-ce que
vous voulez laisser votre nom tous ceux
qui ont voulu laisser leur nom l'ont
généralement pas laissé et c'est
l'histoire qui juge et donc oui on
aimerait tous après faut essayer d'agir
opportunité de faire de grandes chos fa
faut toujours en politique et en règle
générale d'ailleurs c'est la philosophie
que j'essaie de porter pour moi-même
c'est d'essayer d'être modeste quand
même et en même temps d'être très
ambitieux et donc oui j'aimerais en tout
cas être le ministre qui a un
réconcilié monde agricole et
l'agriculture avec la société or il y a
a il y aatus qui s'est créé il y a un
faussé qui s'est créé ce que disent les
agriculteurs c'est comprenez-nous
entendez-nous vous gouvernement vous
Europe et vous qui vous collectivement
société donc c'est j'aimerais ça et deux
qu'on remette la question de la
souveraineté au cœur du projet européen
qui était le la PAC c'était ça 62 la la
pâac qui est la seule politique intégrée
à ce pointlà c'était un projet
nourrissier de souveraineté de l'UR en
disant on n pas on peut pas se nourrir
aujourd'hui je suis un un ministre qui
dans son ministère encore des tickets
attendez qui a encore dans son ministère
des tickets de rtionnement et donc ça a
existé il y a pas si longtemps l'idée de
pas pouvoir se nourrir donc je veux être
le ministre de la réconciliation et le
ministre de la souveraineté assumer
retrouvver concrètement et pour répondre
aux trois questions qui sont posées par
notre Agur je non non je voulais juste
vous demander avant est-ce que pour vous
le contexte parce que c'est la question
et la première question que que vous
posez cet agriculteur est-ce que le
contexte et le moment est bien pour
faire de grand
chos il y a il y a il y a jamais il faut
toujours faire de grandes choses on peut
pas être dans un contexte sinon faut
c'est renoncer à l'activité politique si
vous dites que c'est parce que c'est
difficile qu'il faut rien faire alors il
faut rentrer chez soi il vous demande
d'être ambitieux oui mais c'est ce que
j'essaie de vous dire et c'est ce que
j'essaie de vous dire depuis le début de
notre émission il faut être ambitieux il
faut être ambition il faut batailler au
niveau européen puis batailler en France
nous-même il faut batailler au niveau
européen donc oui le moment est on est
un point de jonction au niveau européen
en particulier sur lequel on a besoin de
réaffirmer le projet européen dans son
objectif de souveraineté dans un monde
qui est quand même singulièrement
perturbé par des puissances qui ne nous
veulent pas que du bien je fais quand
même trois réponses par qu' m'a posé
trois questions sur MHE les on ouvre le
guichet à la fin maladie touchant les
vaches oui la maladie touchant les
vaches on ouvre le guichet fin janvier
début février donc ça va aller très vite
pour pouvoir soulager les trésorerie
deuxième élément on a un suet attendez
juste sur ces aides ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire de l'argent en frais tout de
suite c'est 80 % de prise en charge des
frais vétérinaires et de la perte d'un
animal 80 % pour l'un 80 % pour l'autre
on a on on a fait des choses simples et
on va faire un guichet simple g le
gasoil on a un sujet c'est un accord au
niveau national avec la profession
agricole manifestement et ça faut
l'expertiser donc je suis d'accord pour
l'expertiser parce qu'il y a des
territoires ou manifestement c'est un
impact qui nétait pas celui prévu par
qui que ce soit et donc on a besoin de
regarder dans ces zones intermédiaires
les difficultés qui sont posé trè
élément le gazoil est détaxé il est
détaxé il a été compensé intégralement
par le gouvernement puisque c'est un jeu
de Somme nul ce n'est pas une économie
budgétaire on a prévu des mécanismes
fiscaux qui permettaient de renvoyer
dans les exploitations manifestement il
y a un certain an non d'exploitation
dans lesquel ce renvoie ne se fait pas
et donc l'objectif CIT pour faire simple
pourquoi le gasoel est pas est pas
détaxé d'une manière générale pour la
profession et le le sujet est réglé non
mais il est détaxé en soi on a on a on a
limité on réduit l'avantage fiscal sur
le gazoil je rappelle je rappelle qu'on
a un gazoile autour d'un € un peu moins
en France et un 7 en en Allemagne
d'ailleurs la présidente Lambert le
disait le disait dans les dans les
journaux je crois et donc l'idée c'est
de trouver une trajectoire de sortie
progressive alors sans à sortir
complètement d'ailleurs de de cet
avantage fiscal mais de le transformer
en un en un avantage qui permet de
garantir la productivité on a des
territoires manifestement ah donc vous
voulez s retrou pas cibler en fait oui
faut regarder faut documenter le
problème pour regarder quels sont les
mécanismes fiscau qui permettra dever
vous allez encore créer de la paacerie
non mais c'est pas de la papracerie
c'est les sujets fiscaux non c'est pas
la papracerie SIL faut rempir des papers
pour av une il faut qu' le documente
parce qu'il y a des territoires O
manifestement ça ne produit pas ces
effets là et manifestement en ocitanie
ça produit ces effets là essayons de
regarder ce qui a pu dysfonctionner faut
en politique faut
si je viens devant vous et je dis que je
sais tout j'ai la science infuse et que
nos dispositifs sont parfaits je crois
que je fais une petite erreur et donc on
a besoin de le documenter par ailleurs
sur les question
g un avantage fisc c'est compliqué parce
que vous savez l'égalité fiscale est une
chose mais est-ce qu'il faut quelque
chose qui qui ajuste dans ces territoir
là où ils ont des contraintes qui sont
particulières par rapport vous dit c'est
compliqué c'est bien ce qu'on vous
reproche partie des reproches mais la
question n'est pas de faire un sujet
compliqué des sujets fiscaux c'est au
fiscalistes de regarder les sujets et
après il faut que ce soit simple pour
c'est pas parce que le sujet est
compliqué qu'il faut pas qu'on a des
dispositif simple pardon les sujets
fiscaux sont complexes mais pour les
Français souvent c'est assez Simp trème
élément sur l'au j'ai demandé au préfet
il y a 120 projets on a demandé à ce
qu'il soit mis sur la table tout de
suite pour regarder là où il y avait des
blocages pour débloquer j'annoncerai
demain des moyens supplémentaires en
terme de fond d'hydraulique c'était
prévu j'irai en vender pour le faire
pour donner aux agriculteurs la capacité
à faire par ailleurs je l'ai dit il y a
quelques semaines d'ailleurs dans ce
territoire nous avons des fonds de
transition c'est environ 120 millions
d'euros qui sont prévus évidemment moi
je suis prêt à ce qu'on regarde en
Occitanie sous la réserve que nous ayons
un projet de transition et de dans ce
projet de transition c'est quel type
d'assolement quel type d'agriculture
quel type de réserve en eau et donc ces
moyens là ils sont à la disposition
aussi en partie de l'Occitanie pour le
faire voilà trois réponses concrètes sur
ces sujets derère derrière l'eau il y a
un autre sujet qui est la pollution de
l'eau par les pesticides l'an dernier le
gouvernement avait relancé le plan ecyo
2030 qui voulait réduire diviser encore
avec objectif de diviser par de
l'utilisation des pesticides est-ce que
ce plan vous le maintenez ou pas on a
besoin de trouver une trajectoire le
plan le plan c'est un plan qui est issu
du Grenel de l'environnement donc c'est
un c'est une affaire qui est assez
lointin l'erreur qu'on a fait sans doute
à l'époque c'est de dire on donne un
objectif on donne pas les moyens oui il
a été relancé deux fois depuis he oui
mais c'est je suis d'accord avec vous je
dis on donne un objectif on donne pas
les moyens la nouveauté c'est que dans
le budget que je qui a été délibéré et
voté à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
il y a 250 millions d'euros pour trouver
les alternatives donc je propose qu'on
on regarde l'objectif et quand même
temps surtout on cherche les
alternatives donc pour vous sans
alternative pas de réduction mais c'est
c'est une évidence s'il y a pas
d'alternative et que euh à l'extérieur
de nos frontières les gens utilisent des
produits qui sont interdits chez nous à
la fin c'est la c'est la on se désarme
et il y a plus de souveraineté donc on a
besoin mais il faut qu'on trouve les
deux c'est-à-dire qu'il faut qu'on ait
des trajectoires qui soient crédibilisé
par des alternatives est-ce que
collectivement nous ne sommes pas
incapables de réduire les pesticide
c'est ce que regrettent des députés dans
un récent rapport il parle d'impuissance
publique est-ce que comme eux vous
parleriez d'échec il y a une part
d'échec mais c'est de 15 ans ou 20 ans
d'échec pourquoi parce qu'on n pas mis
les moyens le le Premier ministre hier
était dans le rô il a parlé de le sujet
de la serie
on met en place un plan de recherche sur
la sererise qui aurait dû être mis en
place il y a 15 ans pour essayer de
trouver des alternatives la question des
alternatives c'est la question des
moyens qu'on met sur la table en en
rassemblant les producteurs les
instituts techniques lesinrae les
chercheurs et c'est comme ça qu'on va
trouver et on trouve des solutions sur
un certain nombre de sujet donc oui on n
pas été assez loin dans les alternatives
et donc il faut qu'on mette les moyens
c'est ce qu'on fait il me semble que ça
c'est un élément on a du retard vous
l'admettez mais on n pas du retard par
rapport à d'autres pays on a réduit de
95 % les molécules on les appelle cmr1
les plus toxiques 95 % on a réduit de 85
% les molécules cmr2 2e niveau donc on
n'a pas rien fait on a réduit de
quasiment 30 % simplement sans mettre en
situation d'impasse les usages du
glyphosate h et on est le seul pays du
monde à l'avoir fait donc on n pas on
est largement en avance par rapport à
d'autres pays sauf que à marche forcée
sans qu'on se pose la question de la
souveraineté on y arrive pas donc on a
besoin de mettre des moyens très
puissant pour faire en sorte qu'on
trouve des alternatives et le sujet
européen revient puisque on a besoin
aussi des alternativ offer par les
nouvelles techniques génomiques alors
justement au niveau européen et on l'a
évoqué très très rapidement dans la
première partie du du Grand Jury euh
pour soutenir les Ukrainiens dans leur
guerre l'Europe a ouvert ses frontières
à l'agriculture ukrainienne des secteurs
entiers aujourd'hui s'estiment menacés
par cette concurrence il y a les
producteurs de volail les céréaliés et
avant de parler de la dimension
politique de cette situation que
répondez-vous aux agriculteurs français
alors est-ce qu'il faut refermer
partiellement ou totalement la frontière
avec avec mon collègue ukrainien faut
qu'on regarde notamment sur la question
de la volaille dans quelle mesure ça
vient tellement déstabiliser les marchés
qu'il faut pas réexaminer cette
solidarité sur certaines filière à cette
t là deuxièmement à quelle échéance ah
bah c'est dans les dans les semaines qui
viennent que ça va se faire donc ça ça
va aller assez vite et il faut qu'on y
travaille en européen parce que là la
question c'est ce que porte la France
mais c'est de trouver
27 pays qui disent la même chose donc 26
+ 1 nous et les autres donc on a besoin
de trer j'ai toujours dit d'ailleurs y
compris de manière publique qu' y avait
un moment où ça déstabilisait tellement
les marchés que c'était contreproductif
dans la solidarité que nous voulions
j'ai été en Ukraine le dire et donc
maintenant il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver une solution au niveau européen
pour dire ça déstabilise trop nos marché
et on a besoin de trouver une voix
est-ce que vous prvoyez des aides pour
les agriculteurs qui sont il y a des
aides et et on va regarder ça avec la
Commission européenne qui ont déjà été
donné en particulier sur le front de
l'Est si je peux dire en Pologne et en
Roumanie en Bulgarie pour pour exprimer
cette solidarité où eux ils avaient un
gros problème vis-àvis des céréales
deuxième élément il faut qu'on aide les
Ukrainiens à sortir leurs marchandises
de chez eux pas vers l'Europe vers
ailleurs et donc c'est tous les couloirs
de solidarité sur lesquels on traverse
on travaille pour faire en sorte que ce
qui était leur vocation première
pourquoi ces produits viennent sur notre
sol d'abord parce qu'on a une grosse
crise aviaire et donc on avait moins de
production donc c'est venu comme ça
aussi il faut se le dire on a résolu en
partie cette crise grâce à la
vaccination nous sommes le premier pays
en Europe à avoir fait la vaccination et
les producteurs le reconnaissent mais
deuxième élément faut dire il faut
accompagner les ukraines dans leur
stratégie en dehors de nos frontières
parce que sinon évidemment ça vient
déstabiliser les marchés donc on a une
grande vigilance sur le sujet ce
contexte est-ce que faire entrer
l'Ukraine dans l'Union européenne c'est
un processus de long terme bien sûr ce
n'est pas exposer nos agriculteurs à une
menace alors il y a deux sujets il me
semble-t-il un tout processus d'adésion
nécessite qu'on ait les mêmes normes
donc il est pas question de faire
rentrer qui que ce soit l'Ukraine ou
d'autres sans que ça n'adopte les mêmes
normes 2uxiè élément l'Ukraine elle est
là qu'elle soit dans l'Europe ou pas
dans l'Europe elle est à nos frontières
c'est une puissance agricole majeure à
l'égal de du Brésil à l'égal de la
Russie donc elle est à nos frontières
donc il vaut mieux qu'on se mode qu'elle
soit dedans ou à l'extérieur de l'Europe
je pense qu'on a intérêt à s'en faire un
allié pour aller mener la bataille
alimentaire à l'extérieur de nos
frontières parce que je préfère que ce
soit nos alliés qui mè cette Bata là que
nos adversaires vous voyez ce que je
veux dire et donc on a besoin dans le
processus de réflexion sur l'adhésion de
dire de toute façon ça peut pas se faire
sans les mêmes normes parce que sinon on
reviendrait sur les mêmes problèmes et
deuxième élément en tout état de cause
de dire à l'Ukraine on doit faire de du
continent européen dans ce qu'il est une
puissance agricole pour aller batailler
sur les marchés mondiaux dans un
contexte où le dérèglement climatique
les dérèglements géopolitiques
la démographie quand même puisquon va
passer de 7 à 9 milliards va faire que
les besoins alimentaires vont être plus
nombreux et la tension alimentaire va
être plus nombreuse vous ne craignez pas
que la question de la concurrence
déloyal parasite pollue votre campagne
des élections européennes non mais
certains vont essayer de s'en faire
l'écho mais national vous attaque
particulièrement oui oui il nous
attaqueent particulièrement là-dessus
alors d'abord moi je suis très intéressé
de voir le d'aboord le Front national le
rassemblement national monsieur Bardella
découvre les l'intérêt de l'agriculture
j'aurais aimé qu'en 5 ans il s'exprime
un peu plus souvent sur l'agriculture et
qui mène des batailles il s'est déplacé
hier en giron c'est pour ça vous dites
ça déplacé une fois en Gironde et il dit
il faut aller sur le terrain c'est
content je suis content qu'il découvre
ce que c'est que des bottes mais
j'aurais aimé qu'il découvre
l'agriculture avant pour tout vous dire
pour être plus clair parce que c'est
bien de parler de de l'agriculture quand
il s'agit de s'en servir parce que c'est
ça le sujet et deuxième élément le
rassemblement national il vient nous
expliquer toujours qu'il vient défendre
le patriotisme mais enfin qui est le
parti de l'étranger c'est le
rassemblement national parce que qui
défend les Russes qui défend la
stratégie de Poutine qui a été financé
par Poutine qui nous a dit qu'il fallait
pas de solidarité avec
l'Ukraine c'est eux eu au fond ils
nourrissent un sentiment qui est faux
parce que en disant cela c'est ce qui
dérègle les marchés c'est pas les
Ukrainiens c'est les amis de Monsieur
bardellaa c'est-à-dire monsieur Poutine
c'est eux qui sont responsables de
l'augmentation de l'inflation de
l'énergie et c'est eux qui nous ont dit
qu'il fallait que c'était un être
pacifique et que c'était il fallait se
s'accommoder par dites beaucoup de chose
vous dites pas que l'Ukraine dérègle les
marchés européens non mais ce qui
dérègle les marchés c'est que
l'raine c'est la guerre d'accord ne peut
plus sortir ses céréales h vers les
pays-tiers et que donc par les couloirs
de solidarité on a des sujets qui sont à
créés donc on a besoin jeve affirme ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure de faire en
sorte que l'Ukraine sorte ses produits
d'Europe pas pour sorte ses produits de
son territoire pas pour les amener en
Europe mais pour les amener sur ses
marchés les
initiaux est-ce qu'il y a pas un un
piège politique qui est en train de se
refermer sur vous c'est-à-dire que
quelque part le poulet ukrainien ou la
céréale ukrainienne est en train de
devenir le le plombier polonaise qu'on
avait vécu en en 2005 c'est tenttive
c'est l'Europe qui finalement crée des
conditions de concurrence rons
fond revenons au fondement de la crise
la crise elle est pas provoquée par les
Ukrainiens faut pas inverser les rôles
la crise elle est provoqué par la guerre
qui a mené monsieur Poutine en Ukraine
c'est ça la vérité sauf aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs on un souci AC donc on a
besoin de solidarité avec l'Ukraine et
de vigilant sur un certain nombre de
marchés qui sont désorganisés et de
faire en sorte qu'on aide les Ukrainiens
à sortir leur production de leur
territoire pour aller vers des pays
tiers c'est ça qu'il faut faire parce
que sinon euh monsieur bardellaa peut
dire ce ce qu'il veut ça sert à rien si
Monsieur Poutine revenait dans ses
frontièr et cesser la guerre je vous
assure que les marchés seraient
stabilisés c'est la première question
c'est le premier appel que devrait
lancer monsieur bardellaa c'est de dire
à son ami Monsieur Poutine arrêtez la
guerre arrêtez la guerre parce que c'est
ça qui est le ça veut pas dire que nous
renvoyer le RN à ses positions russes
mais mais c'est je les renvoie pas c'est
la réalité des positions du RN bardé dit
que l'agriculture est une filière
stratégique qui symbolise notre héritage
et notre identité est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça oui tout le monde est
d'accord avec ça la question c'est pas
de le dire et de le déclamer la question
c'est de le faire moi je suis je suis
largement autant rural que Monsieur
Bardella je vis dans un village de 700
habitants donc je sais à peu près de
quoi je parle et sur la ruralité sur
l'agriculture donc il va pas me faire le
coup de l'héritage du patrimoine parce
que ça c'est un mauvais débat s'il veut
qu'il rentre sur ce sujet là il va assez
vite se retrouver perdu lui-même au
milieu des champs si vous me permettez
cette expression le seul sujet c'est pas
seulement un héritage et un patrimoine
c'est une force économique c'est une
c'est une fierté collective et c'est un
él élément stratégique de notre liberté
si vous êtes plus capable de vous
nourrir vous n'êtes plus libre et vous
voyez bien que la stratégie la Russie je
crois augmenter ses capacités de
production par 4 en 20 ans elle les a
augmenté par 4 non seulement pour mourir
nourrir sa population mais elle l'a fait
aussi pour peser sur les débats du monde
pour mettre sous la coupe un certain
nombre de pays et c'est cette bataille
là qu'il faut mener y compris sur les
marchés avec l'Ukraine pour aller sur
ces marchésl voyz veux dire c'est comme
ça qu'on va dénouer la situation je vais
vous poser la question un peu
différemment et ramener à des propos
qu'on a eu y compris dans la première
partie du grand J
dans l'interview commune qu'on donnit
dimanche dernier Marine Le Pen et Jordan
Bardella dans le JDD il déclarait que
l'Europe veut la mort de notre
agriculture par la baisse des rendements
par les accords de libre échange par la
fin des exploitations familiales
traditionnelles et par l'augmentation de
nos importations est-ce que c'est
totalement faux ce constat non mais il y
a pas la question n'est pas la volonté
je crois pas du tout que l'Europe ce
soit sa volonté en même temps je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure dans nos premiers
échanges on a besoin de réexaminer notre
politique agricole et notre politique
européenne à l'ône de ce qu' VO donc les
qu points soulevés sont sont donc il y a
non mais j'ai pas dit autre chose tout à
l'heure j'ai pas attendu que Monsieur
monsieur Bardella ou Madame Le Pen
décide d'en parler oui nous avons besoin
de renouer
avec à la fois la transition et en même
temps le sujet de la souveraineté donc
on a besoin d'une Europe qui s'arme d'un
point de vue de la souveraineté on a
besoin d'avoir des réglementations qui
permettent de combiner les deux on a
besoin d'avoir une réglementation qui
soit pas m par une volonté de
décroissance oui ça c'est un élément
important de c'est la France qui a porté
la question des clauses c'est la France
qui s'est opposé personne peut dire le
contraire au Mercosur et à l'accord
australien qui d'autre c'est définitif
ça non mais sur l'Australie en tout cas
on en est pour longtemps sur le Mercosur
on continue à s'opposer pourquoi il est
pas signé parce que nous sommes là et
donc on peut pas nous faire un reproche
oui on a besoin d'accord en même temps
de on a besoin d'accord internationau s
après le après les élections européenes
vous êtes sûr que le sujet c'est pas
celui-là nous on dit que tant que le ah
non c'est pas le sujet du calendrier ce
que je veux dire c'est pas sujet sujet
qui concerne
les nous opposons au Mercosur en ce
qu'il ne répond pas aux objectifs en
particulier aux objectifs climatiques
bon donc on continue à s'opposer au
Mercosur et jusqu'à nouvel ord personne
ne peut nous mettre en défaut de cette
question là pour le traité de libre
échange entre l'Union européenne et la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors la
Nouvelle-Zélande l'accord a été signé
mais reconnaissons que la
NouvelleZélande reconnaissons que la
Nouvelle-Zélande on peut pas non plus et
ça permettra de faire une toute un petit
là-dessus la Nouvelle-Zélande a la
descuctions de production extrêmement
extensive alors elle n'est pas
totalement alignée sur nous mais sur la
question climatique elle est totalement
alignée le sujet central le sujet
mondial c'est le sujet climatique et du
carbone et la Nouvelle-Zélande elle est
dans on peut
pas'est- qu'est-ce qu' apporte cet
accord avec la Nouvelle-Zélande on a va
importer de l'agneau congelé 19000 km
des qui seront sans doute d'ailleurs
voyage quel est l'intérêt pour l'Europe
d'ouvrir un par Y a d'autres il y a
d'autres sujets sur lesquels sur les
services et sur d'autres sur lesquels on
pe dép de l'agriculture alors mais un
accord un traité d'échange c'est un
traité d'échange donc il y a des accords
où c'est plutôt l'agriculture il y a des
accords où c'est plutôt les services il
y a des accords où c'est plutôt en terme
d'écologie elles sont assurées avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande elles sont totalement
assurées oui elles sont pardon
d'ailleurs personne ne vient mettre en
cave certains viett on fait faire 19000
km de voyage très nous alors après on on
va se poser des questions notre vin il
va il fait combien de milliers de
kilomètres nos spiritueux ils font
combien de kilomètres notre port il fait
combien de kilomètres notre blé qui va
nourrir le monde oui on est dans un
monde interconnecté et c'est là ce que
je voulais en venir arrête arrêons
d'accréditer la teste que nous pourrions
vivre en régime autarcique la moitié de
nos céréales elles sortent de nos
frontières en Europe ou dans le monde et
c'est important de peser dans le monde
quand tout nourrit les gens euh l'excès
le une grande partie de notre filière
monsieur Bardella hier était dans en
Gironde il leur propose quoi de fermer
les frontières au bord de lait alors que
le sujet c'est justement qu'on exporte
plus et les écords internationaux c'est
où où le le commerce sans accords
internationaux c'est il y a des produits
qui rentrent il y a des produits qui
sortent et et il y a pas besoin d'aller
sur les céréales euh euh le fromage
français et l'Europe nous protège avec
ses appellations parce qu'elle évite
qu'il y a des gens qui euh parlent de
camamber dans des pays où on fait pas du
Cambert c'est 3 milliards d'euros donc
on le disait derrière toutes ces
questions il y a la question des
élections européennes ça j'ai bien noté
que certains le faisaient par ce pr ou
une petite parenthèse le camp
présidentiel est le dernier parti qui
n'a pas de tête de liste êtes-vous par
exemple favorable à une candidature de
Julien de N Normandie qui était votre
prédécesseur à
l'agriculture c'est pas moi qui vais
décider là vous allez mettre en
situation de défaut mais vous vous vous
doutez bien que contenu d'abord ça ça
commence à manquer de pas avoir de de
candidat attendez je réponds à votre
question me faites pas deux questions en
une oui en tout cas moi je trouve que
Julien de Normandie a apporté beaucoup
au gouvernement quand il y était c'est
une personnalité que les Français
connaissent et avec lequel pour le coup
j'ai des relations je crois amicales et
cordiales donc oui après il appartiend
estce faire une bonne tête de liste si
l'agricult je trouve qu'il incarne
quelque chose qui serait utile à la
majorité alors est-ce que c'est au
travers d'une tête de liste ou autre
chose mais moi je pense que Julien
Julien de Normandie a quelque chose qui
qui qui est utile dans le débat public
et donc oui je trouve que c'est bien
alors après est-ce que c'est un un un
problème je crois que les les décisions
vont se prendre assez rapidement je suis
pas sûr là on est en train de rentrer
dans le débat européen pour certains en
tout cas qui essaent de le faire rter
par ce tropisme là je suis pas sûr que
nos concitoyens soit totalement dans le
sujet européen mais il faut faire du
sujet européen un sujet central parce
que l'avenir de la France c'est c'est
l'Europe vous pouvez pas aller discuter
avec la Chine avec les Russes avec les
Ukrainiens avec tous les autres avec les
Américains si vous êtes français
italiens espagnol séparé on pèsera rien
dans cet espace là et quand vous le
voyez c'est des c'est des des empires
qui se sont tié parfois hostile pour
certains d'entre eux et donc on a besoin
plutôt d'avoir une Europe un qui se
concentre sur ces sujets deux qui
parlent de souveraineté à tous les étage
et d'un candidat l'énergie les
composants l'agriculture et le reste et
d'un candidat et qui essaie d'avancer et
d'un candidat pour défendre tout ça et
d'un candidat pour le faire bien sûr
mais ne vous inquiétez pas on aura un
candidat ouais mais il y a il y a pas il
y a pas urgence
là prend le débat public je je je crois
que les décisions se prendront dans les
prochaines semaines ne confondons pas
vitesse et précipitation comment
résumez-vous la la conférence de de
presse du du chef de l'État mardi soir
bah je pense que ça a permis d'abord de
remettre en perspective ce que nous
avons fait et la cohérence de ce que
nous avons fait depuis 6 ans les
difficultés que nous avons rencontré et
puis l'affirmation quand même que je
pense au sujet de simplification au
sujet d'autorité que nous avions besoin
de réaffirmer un C est-ce que ça
expliquait le changement de Premier
ministre ça justifiait le changement de
Premier ministre Paron on est dans
l'institution de la 5e République c'est
le président de la République qui est
gardien à la fois euh de du temps et
deuxièmement du choix qu'il fait de
Premier ministre et gouvernement fait on
pas parce qu'à propos du du choix de
Gabriel Atal pour le poste donc de de
Premier ministre le président modem de
la commission des affaires étrangères
Jean-Louis bourlange a confié au monde
faute de pouvoir se représenter Emmanuel
Macron a choisi de se reproduire est-ce
que vous percevez un mimétisme une
troublante ressemblance entre les deux
hommes non je crois pas du tout que ça
soit la volonté du Président de la
République il avait donné il avait voulu
marquer aussi c'est vrai que d'abord
faut rendre hommage au travail qui a été
fait par ellisabeth borne parce que moi
j'aiétis à ses
côtés j'ai vu quatre premier ministres
Elisabeth borne elle a porté des
réformes qui étaient des réformes
compliquées y compris dans l'opinion
publique je pense aux retraite et ce ce
qui a été fait compris sur les sujets
d'immigration après que dans la 5e
République alors c'est une spécificité
française quand on ouvre une nouvelle
temporalité souvent ça s'accompagne d'un
changement de Premier ministre le
président de la République l'a fait
d'autres l'ont fait avant lui beaucoup
d'autres l'ont fait avant lui donc
est-ce que vous considérez que le
Président de la République va donner
plus d'autonomie à Gabriel Atel qu'
qu'il ne l'a fait c'est pr mais j'ai
enfin c'est c'est curieux comme en 5e
République le celui qui est maître du
sourage universel celui qui est issu du
suffrage universel c'est le président de
la République donc il est dans une autre
situation que dans Démocr dans des
démocraties où c'est les premiers
ministres qui sont issus d'une majorité
parlementaire dans la 5e République le
président de la République il a une
place prééminente et éminente et il n'a
pas semblé pour en avoir vu trois et
désormais quatre à l'œuvre que les
Premier ministre n'avait pas leur marge
et le sur l'qu gouvernementale le
gouvernement n'est pas encore au complet
il doit être composé complètement d'ici
une dizaine de jours euh combien de
ministres modemes attendez-vous non mais
la question c'est trouver des équilibres
il y a ici Jean-Noël barreot et je vais
saluer le travail la question c'est pas
numérique c'est la question c'est la
qualité sans faire de mauvais jeux de
mots la question c'est la qualité aussi
des ministres que nous avons et moi
jeaais salué le travail des ministres du
modemme les autres aussi mais en
particulier ceux Jean-Noël Barot
Philippe Vig Sarah etar du travail
qu'ils ont fait je suis pas un épicier
non plus on est des gens qui somt en
situation de responsabilité je ne doute
pas je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que
le premier ministre et le président de
la République trouveront les équilibre
et la reconnaissance du travail qui a
été fait par mes collègues et d'autres
collègues et donc je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude dans le moment cont
pas que le moment agricole si vous
commencez à être dans ce genre
d'exercice que j'ai vu parfois sous
d'autres quinquen vous rentrez dans une
logique qui est très mauvaise malgré
tout la question des équilibres elle est
importante vous le savez j'ai dit que la
question et que je ne doutais pas que la
question des équilibres serait respectée
j'ai aucun motif à douter de cette
question des équilibr une toute dernière
question rapide il y a aujourd'hui des
manifestations contre la loi immigration
attendez-vous du Conseil constitutionnel
qu'il sensure la semaine prochaine une
bonne part de la loi immigration mais
j'attends rien d'autre du Conseil
constitutionnel qui nous disent la
lecture qu'il fait de la loi à l'ône de
la Constitution et ça tu a toujours fait
le Conseil constitutionnel donc moi je n
président le président de la République
attend du Conseil constitutionnel attend
qu'il dise le président de la
République donc j'attends la même chose
le président de républque comm nous qui
vous g ou pas il y a des points qui vous
gênent dans cette loi moi pas
fondamentalement je pense que la
question des étudiants est une question
qui est un sujet qui est un sujet
important après j'ai l'impression que
sur un certain nombre de sujets on a
essayé d'avancer nous sommes en majorité
relative nous sommes d'une certaine
façon dans la nécessité de trouver des
compromis les compromis c'est pas tout
le monde est sur ma position sinon ça
n'est pas un compromis les compromis
c'estabitué
aussiiroup pour ce grand jur bon
dimanche à tous on se retrouve la
semaine
prochaine